You believe everything that was created
was created through Christ, right?
>> Is that not what the Bible says, sir?
>> No, I I agree. I just want to make sure.
So, everything that was created was
created through Christ. Okay. Was Christ
created?
>> Yes.
>> Was Christ created through Christ?
>> Christ was created through the father.
>> Everything that was created was created
through Christ.
>> Listen. Listen. I understand. If you
give me a chance to respond,
>> then we all can have an understanding.
So, I'm going to do my best to debunk
the trinity. All I ask is that you'd
have the same patience with me as you
have with the previous caller.
>> Well, the previous caller was engaging
and she was trying to deal with this
stuff honestly. So, you if you have that
same attitude.
>> Okay.
>> Absolutely.
>> Wonderful. Wonderful. So, let me get
started.
>> Wait, wait, wait before you go. Sorry.
Do you do you believe Jesus is the
father?
>> No. I believe Jesus at one time Jesus
was not. Jesus was a creation of the
father.
>> Okay. Gotcha.
>> And and through and through the agency
of Jesus, everything else was created.
>> Gotcha. All right.
>> But Okay. So, at one time, Jesus was not
only the father existed.
>> Gotcha. And what what verse do you have
to to help substantiate that?
>> Um, one that comes to mind where it says
he was the firstborn of all creation.
It says David was the firstborn of the
kings of the earth.
>> But we're not talking about David. We're
talking about Jesus.
>> What do you think firstborn means?
>> Huh?
>> What do you think the word firstborn
means?
>> Well, we want parallel to a to to a
human ideology. The first son like my
like my child is the firstborn.
>> David.
>> Now, what
is he saying consistent? How is David
the firstborn though?
>> All right. All right. This is what I'm
saying here, right?
Let me start off with
>> N.
You have to give me a chance to debunk
the trinity. What you doing? You're
controlling the narrative. You're you
controlling the narrative now about
David.
>> Is it okay if I call you source?
>> Absolutely. I don't want to talk about
David. We We revisit it. We can revisit
it later if you want.
>> Listen listen, brother. Listen, listen.
So if you if you're if you are showing
that Jesus was once not right that he
did not exist and that he was created,
you have debunked the trinity.
>> Okay,
>> that's the easiest way to do it.
>> Let me let me get this off. Okay,
>> absolutely.
>> So when you're when you're bringing when
you say Jesus is created because he's
called the firstborn of all creation,
>> right? We're holding you to be
consistent with your train of thought
because you're taking firstborn to mean
the first son, the first thing. Okay?
>> So, you're going to have to explain then
why is David, who we know is the
youngest of eight,
>> and obviously wasn't the first king of
the earth,
>> right?
>> Why is he called the firstborn, the
highest of the kings of the earth?
>> Because that's what Yahweh wanted to
say.
>> But was he the first?
>> I don't know. No, he wasn't the first.
So then how is he the first born?
>> Listen, let's deal with the scripture.
The
>> we are Psalm 8 Psalm 89:27, brother.
>> No, no. You asked me a question. I gave
you the scripture. I said the first
thing that comes to mind is that Jesus
was the firstborn of all creation.
>> Then you moved the goalpost to David.
>> That's not moving the goalpost. It's
called consistency.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Look, I I can't I can't make that's like
look that's like that's like me doing
this, brother. It's like me going to a
Muslim and saying, "Wait, what? You you
believe that God did something
supernatural?
What the?" And they're like, "Wait,
don't you believe in your religion that
God does things supernaturally?" Uh,
we're not talking about that right now.
No, it's I have to be consistent. So,
what you're what's happening with you is
that your argument is not working
because it you can't hold its
consistency.
>> That was never my argument. It was you
just argued that Jesus is created
because of Colossians 1:15.
>> You asked me a You asked me a question.
I gave you the answer of Colossians.
Right. I said because it says so and so
and so. Right now,
>> no, I don't see a problem. I take that
verse from what it says. If the verse
says that Jesus Christ is the firstborn
of all creation and we also know that
all creation was created through him
that means that Jesus Christ is the
supreme shilak shallak of the most high.
Now shallak is the Hebrew word which
means um a agent one who is sent and if
you see the one who was sent who
represents the king then you have seen
the king himself. So that's one of the
reasons why. No, no, it is true in a
Hebrew sense. Remember,
>> pause there. Pause there. Pause there.
>> Let me get this off real quick. Can Can
Let me get this off real quick, please.
>> I'll let I'll let you go ahead and I
>> I appreciate. So, we have to remember
that the first century Christians were
mostly Hebrew. So, they understood the
shall principle. You understand? They
didn't believe the first century
Christians did not believe in the
trinity. The trinity was developed over
a course of 300 years later. Now anybody
can Google right now first century
Christians believe in the trinity
doctrine
>> source source material. So look
>> yes sir
>> this is a conversation not for you to go
on in a speech. Okay this we got a
dialogue.
>> Wow.
>> I was just saying did you do you feel
like
>> one minute that was okay. Do you feel
like you got your point off?
>> Huh?
>> Do you feel like you got your point
across? Not not quite because I really
want to hone in.
>> Exactly. So because you're you're you're
making a bunch of points right now and
it's going on for a minute.
>> No, go ahead.
>> I'm trying. All right. No problem.
>> So
>> you understand my point about the divine
shil.
>> I understand.
>> Yes.
All power.
I got you. You believe that he's the
highest agent of Jehovah. I got you. I
got you. It's also the angel of the
Lord.
>> Let's deal with this. And the angel of
the Lord, I got you.
>> So, listen. When you said that Jesus is
the firstborn of all creation, and you
said you're taking it for what it means.
Absolutely. I don't know. Have you
watched me before?
>> Absolutely. I watched you before.
>> So, you know that I I'm like a I I when
I grip on something, I don't I don't I
don't let it go, man.
>> Don't let it go. Come with it.
>> You You like that?
>> Come with Come with it. Come with it.
Come with it. All right.
>> Oh, yo, what the
knows it. So listen, when you when you
say that you're taking the verse
>> for what it says,
>> which I'm with you, he's the firstborn
of all creation. So you're like, "Yep,
this means that he's the literal first
creation."
>> So then I need you to be consistent.
Okay.
>> Psalm 89:27.
>> Go ahead.
>> It says that David is the firstborn, the
highest of the kings of the earth,
>> but technically he's the eighth born.
>> Exactly.
>> Right. So, how is he called called the
firstborn?
>> Who called him? Who called him the
>> God.
>> That's who that's who we have to take it
up with. Because now you want me to to
to go into the mind of God and say this
is why God called him the firstborn.
Even though he was the eighthorn
above my ways and his and his thoughts
is above my thoughts. He decides to call
an eighthborn child the firstborn.
>> If you listen, I can help you.
>> We got to take it up in prayer. Okay.
>> Okay.
We got to take it up a prayer.
>> Amen. You got to take it up a prayer,
brother. You got to take it up a prayer.
>> Well, this do here's the thing, source.
Here's the thing. He actually gives us
the answer in the same verse.
>> All right, let's go.
>> Okay, so it the verse goes like this. It
says, "And I have called him my
firstborn, the highest of the kings of
the earth." So, what does this mean?
He's using firstborn as a term to
implement preeeminence supremacy. He's
supreme.
>> That is the show principle.
>> No worries.
>> Represents
source. Please relax brother so we can
talk. So do you see how the term
firstborn doesn't always mean the very
first thing of a group that context?
Yes.
>> Very good. So context will tell us how
the term firstborn is being used right
>> not all the time in that context just
>> I know so context will tell us do you
agree context will tell us how the word
is used right context will tell us
>> yeah and there's different contextes
right
>> absolutely so the question is this
source the question is when we go to
Colossians 1:15
>> yes
>> what is the context in which firstborn
is being used is it being used to denote
that Jesus is the first thing created or
is it being used to denote that Jesus is
supreme over creation? That's what we
need to look at. Okay.
>> Okay. So, you believe that Jesus is
supreme over creation?
>> Absolutely. That's what it says.
>> Me too. Me too. I agree with you because
he created everything.
>> All right. So, now
>> there's there's no argument there.
>> No, there is an argument still because
you still when you
>> I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE. YOU WANT TO
ARGUE. I don't want to argue. I want to
understand it.
>> Okay. So, look,
>> you want to argue
>> when you when you when you have Look,
I'm just trying to help, bro. I'm just
trying to help.
>> So, when you have when you have in
Colossians, when you even you say that
Jesus created everything, guess what?
Does
>> that say that?
>> Yep. It says that it say that. Yep.
That's the truth. We agree.
>> So, look, we agree.
>> If Jesus created everything,
>> that means that Jesus himself is not
created. He's always been. That's not
what the scripture said. The scripture
says,
>> "I'mma keep I'mma hook on like a pit
bull." It says he was the firstborn of
creation. Now, what you did, you found a
similarity of the context of firstborn
or the term firstborn when it was
applied to David because he was the
eighthborn, right? And you saying,
"Well, he's the eighthborn, then it's
not literally that David was the
firstborn. So, why was he called the
firstborn?" And then you said because he
being a king and he has supreme
eminence.
>> I'm glad you agree that everything was
created through Christ. But I do so you
believe everything that was created was
created through Christ, right?
>> Is that not what the Bible says, sir?
>> No, I I agree. I just want to make sure.
So everything that was created was
created through Christ. Okay. Was Christ
created?
>> Yes.
>> Was Christ created through Christ?
>> Christ was created through the father.
>> But everything that was created was
created through Christ. Listen, listen.
I understand. If you give me a chance to
respond,
>> sure.
>> We all can have an understanding right
now. Jesus Christ, the Bible says, is
the firstborn of all creation. Jesus,
would you would you agree that Jesus
Christ is in the image of the father?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. He's not answering. Now, here's my
question. Here's my question.
>> Why are you asking?
>> What image is the father in?
>> If Jesus Why you ask the question? I
just asked you one.
>> If Jesus Christ is in the image of the
father,
>> you dodged, brother.
>> Id dodge. I did not dodge. Answer the
question.
>> Remember what he asked you?
>> I asked this question.
>> No, you didn't. He asked you.
>> Okay, let's go back.
>> He said, "You believe Jesus created
everything. Everything that was ever
created was created through Jesus." You
said yes.
>> Uhhuh.
>> He then asked you, "Was Jesus created?"
You said yes. So then he asked you then
so since everything that has been
created was created through Jesus
>> then was Jesus created through Jesus.
>> No
>> then that means not everything
>> so that means not everything was created
through Jesus.
>> Yes. Yes. Because the context is the
context is that Jesus is talking about
the Bible is talking about Jesus
creating creation. So,
>> is Jesus is is Jesus creation?
>> Is Jesus creation?
>> You're taking out of context.
>> Is Jesus part of creation, brother?
>> Jesus is a created unique being.
>> So, he's part of creation. Correct.
>> Wait, wait, wait. He is part of Yahweh
creation.
>> So, is he part of creation or not?
>> He's not a part of the creation that he
created.
>> Is he part of creation or not?
Not
>> brother. Hey source material, brother.
>> Look, man. I'm pretty sure you I'm
pretty sure you and I would have a good
time.
>> We can probably get some good barbecue.
>> Don't run.
>> I got you, man. I got you. I got you. I
got you.
>> Don't run.
>> I love you. I love you, man. I'm praying
for you.
>> You don't love me, bro. Don't Don't lie,
man. But don't
>> I do I love you, bro. Please reflect on
this, man. Watch your clip back, man.
>> There's nothing more you can do, man.
Watch your clip back, bro. There's no
possible way that we could continue
that.
No possible way.
>> Watch your clip back. Let it sink in.
Come back when you get down. Do some
self. Go ahead, watch your clip and
start again. Come back when you get
down.
>> DO YOUR HOMEWORK FIRST UNTIL THEN. YOU
messed up. Don't request up. Go stud.
You messed up. Don't request up. Go
stud. You messed up. Don't request up.
Go stud. You messed up. Don't request
UP. GO STUD.
WATCH YOUR CLIP BACK. WATCH YOUR CLIP
BACK. Watch your clip back. Watch your
clip back. Watch your clip back. Watch
your clip back. WATCH YOUR CLIP BACK.
WATCH YOUR CLIP BACK. WATCH YOUR CLIP
BACK. OKAY.
>> Sometimes people need to just go watch
their clip back and reflect. Go study,
man. You done messed up, so don't
request up and do this.